the jurogan experience
what are we going to do
what it where's what's if you from your
perspective
as a producer of a podcast
that gets seen by millions of people
when you you're looking at things all
the time you're paying attention to
trends you're looking at online activity
metaverse [ __ ] all this stuff
where are we going
something's happening right
civilization is clearly at a tipping
point right
i could be cynical on that and go maybe
because those days i don't look at my
phone
you forget right stuff it's going wild
for sure but eventually it's gonna
affect you like the way you pay your
bills
whether or not you get credit there's
it's going to affect you right if they
if they institute some sort of a social
credit system it's going to affect you
um
are you worried about that at all
yeah i heard someone talk about
something like that over the weekend
but they said like a global credit score
of some kind or something like did you
see the uh we talked about the yahoo
article right where they said that they
were going to base it in some part on
your browser history well they talked
about it yeah yeah yeah where
the the idea is they were floating it
out there that your browser history
might make you available for more credit
so the idea would be that if you gave up
all the [ __ ] you looked up
they would allow you to have more credit
because they know hey well he's not
googling bulletproof vests or [ __ ]
freeze-dried food if they did that
though people would just make burner
accounts to look online
yeah but if they track your [ __ ]
device like who knows what kind of
ability they have to actually track your
phone or your your laptop
right like if edward snowden didn't tell
us about
their ability to essentially like
mass store every [ __ ] phone call and
email you've ever made if edward snowden
didn't tell us about what the nsa was
cooking up we would have never guessed
it
so who knows the [ __ ] is going on right
now
you should assume that everything you
say is constantly being monitored and
recorded whether you're saying it on a
phone off a phone oh look at suzanne
she's back
like will harris shared a post today
about a guy who went uh spent the week
at his mom's house and is now getting
advertisements for his mother's
toothpaste oh my god and they never
talked about it you know but it
explained why why that's happening well
your phone's listening no no it has
nothing to do with that it's it's like
it knows everything you've bought
because of all the terms and conditions
you've you've done so like right that's
checking your email and all that stuff
oh yeah for sure that and then linking
that with like i sort of said this like
a week or two ago it'll have uh your
phone's
social security number if you will it's
like a mobile id number it's there right
eein and all that kind of stuff it's
linking it out with gps data
so it'll know like me and you and
suzanne are all with each other right so
she'll start getting advertisements for
stuff you're buying thinking and hoping
that
you might see uh an advertisement i'm
getting that's what i was like excuse me
mad you missed like hey joe did you see
this thing
i bet you would love this
well well what about when you talk about
something and then you get an ad for
that something that you've never seen an
ad for before it could be it's it's no
coincidence it could have known that you
were watching tv because it's coming
through a streaming service now and it
knows you would have seen the ad so it's
it's read it's re-giving it to you you
know it's like it's redistributing it to
you right like the only reason why i
know about it is i've seen an ad yeah
i've been using youtube tv for two or
three years now
and i recently watched i don't remember
the reason why but like over-the-air
uh
football you know like over the antenna
the advertisements are so different and
i like you don't even realize it right
but i have had conversations with you
or with a lot of people where i'm
talking about something then also i get
an ad for that thing in like google ads
i also think there's a lot of uh it's
how many ads do you get all day that
you're that doesn't happen too and
they're like oh [ __ ] i'm watching that
thing yesterday and also when you
mention it are you mentioning it because
it's in the public zeitgeist and why did
you say it right and then it gets out
there that's possible too like but
that's the thing is like you have to be
like really honest about what what's the
source of whatever the [ __ ] it is
and the problem is people get really
tribal and when they get really tribal
they don't want to admit that maybe they
don't totally understand what's
happening like is my phone listening to
me [ __ ] it might be it seems like it is
definitely might be why wouldn't it be
they definitely have the technology like
if they know if suzanne santos talking
some [ __ ] they could just
listen to that bitch's phone all day
long they know right they know they can
do that if joe rogan is saying something
stupid they can check his phone they
know you know they can i know they can
we all know they can so if that's the
case like well how are they doing that
and are they using that technology
all the time like why would you just use
it on potential criminals or enemies of
the state or what have you what you
could use it on the entire [ __ ]
population and make trillions of dollars
in avatars of revenue like wouldn't you
do that what are you stupid use it on
everybody hey hey guys
we don't we just get metadata we don't
even know who it is we're gonna send the
ads to their phones we give you a little
piece a little taste
it's just ads wire ads like we know
better at least to some extent i don't
offer ads see i don't well some of them
you do i buy coolers i don't need i'm
like i want a blue yeti it looks so good
i'm a [ __ ] but that's what they've
tapped into something else i'll take
your excess coolers i have a cooler one
[Laughter]
there's a bunch of ads you don't fall
for you know
feminine products i saw a [ __ ]
yeah but we sign up for that stuff like
when you
sign your cell phone thing there's all
kinds of [ __ ] in there when nobody
reads terms and agreements when was the
last time you read terms and agreements
anything i think it's a very rare breed
that ever takes the time for that